plusieurs centaines d'enseignants et
étudiants dans la rue ce mardi matin à
tours une petite centaine à blois plus
de postes hausse des salaires et une
prime covit voilà leurs revendications
11 % de grévistes dans l'académie
d'orléans tours aujourd'hui une
délégation syndicale a été reçue vers
11h à tour par la préfète est le nouveau
directeur académique à tour lucas chopin
ils sont 700 membres du personnel
enseignant à avoir battu le pavé entre
les place anatole-france et jean jaurès
à l'appel des syndicats
en cause les trop faibles moyens alloués
à l'enseignement dans le budget de
l'état pour 2021
parmi les manifestants des ash
accompagnant d'élèves en situation de
handicap qui se sentent un visibiliser
nous avons des salaires vraiment très
très bas nous n'avons même pas de réel
statut dans l'éducation nationale
et là on a plein d'enfants qui sont en
attente d'un message donc on demande
vraiment au ministre de faire les choses
comme il se doit c'est-à-dire recrutés
en masse dans les écoles primaires les
craintes se portent notamment sur la
suppression de postes d'enseignants qui
laisse la porte grande ouverte aux
fermetures de classes les communes de
moins de 5000 habitants il n'y avait pas
de fermeture s'il n'y avait pas corps du
maire est très clairement les maires ne
souhaitait pas que les classes
pourraient fermer dans les écoles
rurales
la saignée ce moratoire il a sauté là
depuis deux semaines
donc on s'attend à ce que dans les
campagnes yeah yeah des fermetures de
classes les établissements
d'enseignement secondaire eux devrait
voir débarquer 28 mille élèves de plus à
la rentrée prochaine des effectifs trop
importants par rapport au nombre actuel
d'enseignants un des points principaux
les salaires
deuxième point les moyens qui sont
données pour l'école dans les
établissements secondaires il ya encore
une hausse des effectifs et des
diminutions de postes considérable il ya
aussi une compensation des baisses de
postes par des heures supplémentaires
donc c'est des conditions de travail qui
se dégradent aussi pour les personnels
désormais l'intersyndicale espère une
revalorisation générale des salaires de
l'éducation nationale actuellement les
enseignants français en début de
carrière sont payés sept pour cent de
moins que la moyenne des pays de l'osce
et des oeufs